what is the point of a pocket in
Sterling today we are getting naked for
the internet again we're trying on
valentine's day loans right we're back
baby I have no experience with sexy
lingerie which is kind of sad maybe
it'll get us all in the mood I'm wearing
a dance belt and we're hiding it because
the dance belt still looks gross that's
a button the most great good this is a
corset right of course it is I already
hate this because they're way too many
clasps on it I feel like the sexiest
thing clothes can do is be easy to take
off it's just like the pressure
literally puts that burp out of me like
I'm being punished for dating you how
expensive is this nonsense it's like
Disney version of sex I like booze I'm
looking at this and I'm confused cuz
they're like so many leg holes
oh no that's not a leg hole that's a
butt oh yeah I'm afraid to bend down cuz
the string may never escape me oh this
hurts the fabric is scratching my
stomach they don't show that part in
sexy movies like you know you got to
prepare I think this is more trouble
than it's worth I think if they had this
like in velcro yeah huh this one's
really selling something you know when I
saw this I'm like how do you cover the
boobs the answer is you don't
I need someone's self how can anyone
without an engineering degree figure
this out this is a Rubik's Cube of
lingerie who knew being sexy was so hard
does it look like the box no does it
look like a sexy trainwreck of cables
yes if it's even half as hard to take
off as it was to put on this is not
worth it I don't think men would do
Valentine's Day if they had this type of
suit that's a lot of but I don't think
anyone would look great in this this
doesn't make me feel differently about
Valentine's Day it makes me feel like
I'm not missing much I don't like the
name of that we usually should rename
this now this is what I pictured this is
what I think like lingerie should be a
bet Keefe likes this what else is there
to say it's cute first of all easy
access it's good because I'm flexible to
go in like all different sorts of
positions I feel like a bird like a nice
little gentle breeze on my legs that I
don't I'm not quite used to this one's
cozy I feel like a woman could be sexy
yet come
if my wife wore this I would be turned
on listen I forgot to get you a present
present this is ripped already I assume
Ned is to blame now we're Oh tip this
will make so few people look better I
look like the mayor of a nudist colony
like the day you found out Santa isn't
real so it looks like breasts my boob
keeps popping out get back in there if I
like straighten up
it Rams the string up my butt I just
feel bad the girls always have things up
their butts you know almost like getting
a prostate exam it's very obvious to me
that this is not made for all body types
you better be buying me a nice dinner
tonight I'm talking like oh then we're
going to dessert too
they had man lingerie I'm not doing it I
understand it's a lot of work to put on
Valentine's Day lingerie do I still like
the way it looks and you from trying on
ladies underwear before I already know
it's fairly uncomfortable and sexy this
is just extremely uncomfortable and less
sexy it makes you feel good and it makes
your partner think you look extra great
then I think it's fantastic I mean the
point of this is just like it's like we
just want to have sex right so let's
give this and just get to it mmm hold on
this is the problem with it it's so hard
to take it off once I'm ready once